hello and welcome to nostalgia trip the
show where we here at GameSpot look back
at our favorite games from yesterday and
see if they still hold up today
I'm Mike McCarty here with John Luke
psyche and we are going to look back at
one of our favorite series - the second
game which started a lot of trends we
see today
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
like moths to a flame numerous games
have tried to mimic the brilliance of
the first Dark Souls upon its release in
2011 from software's action RPG
popularized its blend of deliberate
combat punishing difficulty and maze
like world design it refused to hold
your hand opting instead to unfurl
mysteriously before you daring you to
venture farther in game spots original
2011 review kevin van ORD called it a
landmark game destined to be loved and
talked about by anyone who has the
pleasure of unraveling its mysteries so
now with Dark Souls remastered out in
the open we're returning to Lordran to
see if these words ring true
alright so John Luke you're a huge fan
of From Software's portfolio dark souls
remastered just released a few weeks ago
and it was a good chance for us to go
back and we thought we'd look back at
whether it is still worth playing today
in its remastered form or in general
what is it like going back to Dark Souls
especially now that we've played this
two sequels and blood-borne that's also
from you know it's kind of from
software's cousin game right I mean I
think the biggest thing is the pacing
yeah it's like immediately different you
know blood-borne was a way faster game
and then Dark Souls kind of Dark Souls 3
went back to the slower pace but it's
still much faster there's more of an
emphasis on rolling there's a greater
emphasis on managing multiple enemies
you go back to Dark Souls 1 and it feels
a lot more simple where it's like
typically it's all about encounters with
single enemies or maybe two or three and
kind of managing them there's a lot more
emphasis on shield combat as a viable
strategy you can still do rolling but I
feel like it's just deliberately slower
then yeah it's kind of the later games
but I don't think that's a bad thing
no a different way than it's designed
right it's kind of funny to see how like
you mentioned Dark Souls 3 kind of
borrowed something from blood-borne that
made that patch that combat faster paced
it just takes patience which isn't
always you know something you see in
more modern games I want to talk about
the boss fights cuz that's also like
specifically when we're talking about
combat with the dark souls of the souls
borne games the bosses are kind of like
the stars of it when you actually reach
them what are some of your favorite
bosses from Dark Souls that like you've
remembered since playing this game back
in 2011 that
stop winning man so I think there's what
struck me when I first played the game
was that there were bosses that were
difficult in bosses that were like a
spectacle mm-hmm so like a good
spectacle example would be see yeah yeah
the wolf it's not necessarily a hard
fight but it's like a really like the
arena and the setup for and then like
the way Seif like slowly starts like
limping as you're playing it like that's
a fight that just feels like that stuck
with me it felt impactful but I felt
like I'm like they're getting the
storytelling in there mm-hmm but then of
course there's like crazy hard fights
like Ornstein and SMO which is probably
one of the more infamous Dark Souls
bosses yeah that is like that's like the
make-or-break moment in this game and it
still still kicks my ass it was like oh
I got it like I've I'm coming back I've
got all these other Dark Souls games
it's so hard like that fight is still
like just gonna completely kick your ass
that's not the first time in the game
that you fight you know two bosses at
once you do the bell gargoyles earlier
all right and that is kind of first a
really strong test of your positioning
especially when one of the bell
gargoyles is like you know breathing
fire the other one is just swinging with
a tail bird you really have to worry
about positioning which is huge in any
soul born game but especially Dark Souls
but then yeah Ornstein and I say Smaug
that's just what I think here in my head
Ornstein smo it's so indicative of Dark
Souls to me and I do you mentioned kind
of all this storytelling in the combat I
do want to talk about the world and
level design which is something you and
I always gush about when a guy's Souls
born games when you've played
blood-borne by now or even Dark Souls 3
you're used to the way that like finding
a shortcut back to a bonfire or Lantern
in the case of blood-borne is just as
big a deal almost to me at least as
beating a boss you can get back to it
easier you can save all the souls
obviously a big trope or a big conceit
of these games is that you lose all your
experience when you die unless you can
retrieve it before dying again next time
and Dark Souls specifically the first
one is interconnected on a much bigger
scale like that that's what makes Dark
Souls still I think stand up apart from
the rest of the sequences is the level
design and the kind of like spiral
structure where everything's sort of
like layered on top of each other and
you can see everything and I think the
like Demon Souls was much
like broken up into five different
sections that were kind of like linear
and then Dark Souls 2 is very very
linear it's much more of like this kind
of like flat like plane yeah
blood-borne is probably the closest I'd
say to getting back to what Dark Souls
did but even then it still feels a
little bit broken up same with Dark
Souls 3 yeah like Dark Souls 1
everything feels so connected there's
this great part where you are when you
start in Firelink you have immediate
access to well I can go down to the New
Londo ruins I can go to the catacombs I
can go up to the undead burg and then
when you're going to when you finally
get to Blighttown
and you have to get back up you can take
that shortcut it gets you to the valley
of the drakes and it has an immediate
shortcut which gets you right back to
Firelink so just the way everything kind
of connects back to each other through
those shortcuts is something that I
think the other Souls games have never
quite done to the level yeah I think
part of the reason why this one works is
because it doesn't give you fast travel
until over halfway through the game
which is a contentious thing I know a
lot of people don't like that I think it
makes you really like connect with the
world and like memorize exactly how its
laid out I go one step further I wish
that didn't even happen I wish you
didn't have dark fast travel at all at
all I think it would fit the game better
I know that travel is very helpful
especially when you're replaying the
games you're going back with Dark Souls
remastered and you know the game really
well you'd be like oh thank god now I
have fast travel between bonfires I
think it fits the games identity more if
you didn't have fast travel yeah I would
agree I kind of get why they did it I
think it's because when you get to the
second half it opens up where you're
supposed to kind of go back to these
previous areas that you need to unlock
and you can tell they were a little
rushed for time lost izalith is an
infamous example of an area that's like
not done and you can tell when you're
playing it and so I think I bet you
there's at some point in their original
vision was to not have any fast travel
at all it's so amazing to look back at
Dark Souls and go back today especially
I haven't played Dark Souls and maybe
since it released in 2011 it was weird I
remember getting it through Gamefly and
this was I hadn't played Demon Souls I
knew what Dark Souls was I knew who from
software were as a group but I played I
finally got Dark Soul and started
playing it and like we mentioned the
lack of guidance felt so refreshing
they have gotten away from that a little
bit I think they I think you put it
really well a few when we played when
Dark Souls 3 came out you put it really
well I think you said Dark Souls this
was before from software completely knew
what they were doing and it's kind of
shows like mm-hmm they didn't always go
by the rules in the first I mean they
don't in general but like Dark Souls
especially you can tell they did not
give a [ __ ] where they were guiding you
at all yeah yeah there's when you hit
three and you've played all of these
games you start to realize that there's
like certain formulas and safety nets
that they're like oh well you know the
bonfire is probably gonna be here and
the shortcuts gonna be there or the way
bosses in Iraq where you're gonna have
this type of boss like there's sort of
like an archetype of souls type bosses
that you can expect and I think Dark
Souls and especially like Demon Souls
for sure they were like a little more
experimental and didn't necessarily like
because they didn't have all these fan
expectations of like what has to have
this this and there so it felt like
they're a little more free to get weird
with some races and stuff like that like
the moon like butterfly for exactly yeah
it's like such a weird boss and I
absolutely loved it or things like the
PvP yeah like that is like so weird I do
you just mentioned PvP and stuff and I
think like I want to ask a is this game
worth going back to today and I think
obviously if we haven't kind of hinted
at what we think already a reason it's
worth going back to today still what
seven years after it released you can
kind of feel like it's timely and you
were saying you didn't get that when you
first played Dark Souls right I played
it a couple years after so I got the
messages those guys stick around but the
PvP stuff I didn't get as much of it you
get a little bit but it's usually at
that point you're playing with people
who have like new game+ seven characters
and they're just here to troll you it's
really refreshing playing the game with
people and you get to see all the little
touches so for example something a lot
of people probably don't know is when
you ring the bell when you have to ring
the two bells at the beginning of the
game that actually will ring out to
everyone else who's playing so when when
you're playing the game at the beginning
if you hear a bell ring that is because
another player has rung the Bell and you
actually get a free humanity from it
tiny little stuff like that that the
game
like never tells you that's really cool
but then you have the stuff like oh I'm
gonna go fight this boss and you see
like 18 like summon me signs and that's
like I think that's great that like
people have the ability to like oh I'm
having a really trouble this boss oh
there's there's tons of people that I'm
going to help me out and you have all
the covenants like I think they they did
a better job like explaining the
covenants in the later games but this
game still has like that level of of
depth and variety in the Covenant so you
have like a covenant that's entire
designed entirely to troll people like
you're supposed to get in there and just
kill people and like mess their day up
and then you have this item you can get
where you can when someone does that to
you you can mark them in a book yeah and
then if you have that book and you join
this the moonlight the the dark moon
covenant you join the dark moon covenant
you are like an avenging spirit there's
almost like a bounty hunter you go
through the book and you find a person
like oh yeah I'm gonna get that guy and
then you invade their world and you kill
them you get revenge on that person and
so like having these covenants that like
set up these different roles you can
play becomes almost a game in it in
itself like you can you can basically
get to a point in that game where you're
like good enough and you could be like
I'm gonna now play a character who just
helps people fight bosses because I want
to do that or I'm gonna help you know
avenge people who get killed or I'm
gonna go kill people or I'm just gonna
do PvP arena fights like that is
probably one of the most like underrated
aspects of the soul series and I think
it is just as good in this one as it is
in the other ones and I'm really happy
that people are like finally have a
chance to properly experience it yeah
and the original version of the game
some of the covenants were actually
broken like the end the gravelord Serban
us the gravelord servant covenant
wouldn't really work that well and even
then a lot of people weren't in it and
now there's actually like a ton of
people in it right now if you're playing
the remaster and that's great because
it's like cool then here's like a part
of the game that just straight-up didn't
work when people didn't get to
experience and now you get to
well I think we both agree 100% it's
worth going back to eat Oldman with Dark
Souls 2 available 3 blood-borne I loved
blood-borne I used to say blood warms my
favorite Souls born game replaying Dark
Souls I'm almost tempted to put Dark
Souls 1 at the top for me at least yeah
2 is still a bottom then three but Dark
Souls 1 I think after like in hindsight
in a post blood-borne post Dark Souls 3
world
I think Dark Souls my favorite still
okay it probably depends on the day you
asked me I think I do like the level
design more in Dark Souls and then sort
of the way it's all connected but there
is something about the like aesthetic of
blood-borne that I like more and that's
just like a personal preference sure but
I were in gothic exactly like I love
that stuff but there's something about
Dark Souls that I still think is unique
and stands apart like when you think
about like a franchise like this
typically the early like the first game
maybe like holds up the least yeah
especially like a genre right like Dark
Souls you could say like created a genre
technically Demon Souls created a genre
I know but Dark Souls popularized that
genre and created a lot of things that
you know people are like using today and
guns like a surge the Lords of the
Fallen you know yeah stuff like that
and so whatever that happens typically
the first that that original game feels
very dated you think like Gears of War 1
was a great game at the time she was
like really dated yeah games like doom 3
like that were like these kind of early
examples like scripted shooters they
feel super dated Dark Souls 1 doesn't
feel dated in the way those game are and
I think it's because there are things
that it does that later Souls games
never did like the way it's level is
designed yeah and the lack of fast
travel there are obviously some things
that don't hold up like some of the UI
improvements in the later games yeah or
obviously like really welcome changes
but I do think this game holds up
surprisingly well in a way that I think
other games wouldn't hold up yeah it's a
remaster it's a bit it's been noticeable
to see like a lack of shadows especially
like I was telling you I think the one
time I really remembered I was like oh
yeah I'm playing a remaster over 2011
game
and Darkroot garden the trees if you
looked at them from the side they look
like plus signs with like leaves drawn
on that was when I really noticed it but
outside I mean like it was smoother now
if you're playing Dark Souls remastered
I would HIGHLY definitely say play this
as opposed to the actual original game
on 360 ps3 or whatever and obviously
again you get that community feeling
from everybody playing at the same time
so if you play Dark Souls 2 3
blood-borne neo Lords of the Fallen any
of the games that were inspired in part
by Demon Souls but by Dark Souls
popularizing them it is still very much
worth returning to Dark Souls especially
with Dark Souls remastered you able to
play it with thousands of other people
that are just getting into it for the
first time or the tenth time but anyway
this was a nostalgia trip in our book
back seven years after at Dark Souls
which released in 2011 still very much
worth playing today we highly recommend
it
you